more typos or Cody a moody bucket
[Music]
if you visited the regeneration reserves
area recently you would have noticed the
huge change is taking place here all
this activity is known as the enabling
works it's getting everything prepared
for the various recreational facilities
that will be constructed here and it's
got three main components the first work
package is the best work stormwater
management area that is the installation
of a new stormwater basement
the second works package is the earth
work that you can see going on behind me
here so that's the importation of about
50,000 cubes of fill to create a level
playing field for the new sports pitches
and the third works component is the
decommissioning of the existing roads
and utilities the scale of the work is
huge and expected to take about eight
months overlapping that construction of
the facilities such as the sports fields
dog parks and BMX track will be getting
underway Trent Jones grew up riding on
the old car boy B mix track before
eventually representing New Zealand and
BMX at the Rio Olympics
he's currently overseeing the rebuild of
the North Canterbury BMX Club track and
will design the new tracking coefficient
to the general I it just looks like some
dirt and some some calls here and Paul's
there but the shapes and then kind of
design and final features are very
specific to our sport the proposed track
will be wide enough to accommodate for
bikes at a time and Trent has some key
factors driving his design my first
thought is fun that's obviously the end
goal is to have as much fun as possible
safety is the second one and then all
around just being able to cater for that
widespread of individual and skill level
you've got everyone from five and under
all the way through to 55 and plastic
and you know attend there and have that
kind of thrill off of riding the bike
and challenging themselves construction
of the BMX track is scheduled to start
early in the new year
well we're aware that this has been a
popular area for walking and cycling
it's really important that people stay
clear of the worksite for their own
safety and the safety of their
contractors we'll take another look at
progress here and at the marine precinct
early next year
[Music]
for more information about the
regeneration visit any council service
center or Waimakariri govt tnz ford /
regeneration
[Music]